berry is one of the so-called red wall
towns across the midlands on the north
of england that traditionally voted
labour but in
2019 swung to the conservatives labour's
working-class heartlands turned blue
delivering boris johnson an overwhelming
majority
and inside number 10 that support seems
to be holding up i think he's done
incredible so not many other people
could you know take the lead and drive
the country and the way it's been driven
during the pandemic yeah during the
pandemic so you guys basically firm
tourists you know you're very happy to
see things pretty much continue as they
are yeah yeah but elsewhere things are
changing and 2019
seems a lifetime ago
before covert 19 and the lockdowns that
this coffee shop was lucky to survive
many didn't before the war in ukraine
and the cost of living crisis before the
parties in downing street and the prime
minister who once delivered brexit but
who many now feel is a liability
i did have faith in him you know and
because i did vote for him to you know
to be elected um
but
at the moment i'm just not sure
he's made a few mistakes
and particularly with
his behavior over covid
and um
i don't think i'll be voting
conservative this time
on the campaign trail the conservatives
are keen to keep the conversation
strictly local the prime minister is not
the person who will be filling the
potholes on their street the media might
want to talk about downing street what
we're focused on is their street right
okay
labour party activists though are only
too happy to exploit their opponent's
woes
and what do you think about the current
conservative government yeah
right i wouldn't trust boris to save my
life okay i wouldn't
you've got a lack of trust in government
because they see some people getting
away with it so you know whether that's
tax whether that's partying people not
obeying the law
you get to a point then where people are
saying you know what i'm just so sick of
it and that's what we're getting at the
moment on the doorstep municipal council
elections despite their obvious focus on
local issues can often be a useful
indicator of where national politics are
heading so if opinion polls predicting
major conservative losses are correct
especially across these former red wall
areas well that could be a sign that the
blue defense may not hold when the next
national election comes around
which is why these elections could spell
trouble for boris johnson here on a
visit to bury last week
a bad set of results could be the
trigger for a vote of confidence in the
prime minister he's already facing the
possibility of more police fines for
those locked down rule-breaking parties
and an inquiry into whether he lied
about them to parliament jonah al
jazeera berry